bom dia a todos estou a ver bem a minha
apresentação vai ser um grid frente às
apresentações dos meus colegas de pau
distante
eu não vou falar do custo de vida da
história da forma como ambos o amor que
tentou mas vou também contar uma
história e como uma bússola orientou
alguns dos nossos antepassados que geram
um grande contributo para a história da
ciência
esta é uma imagem da terra toca
conselhos a partir de fotografias
tiradas por satélites em órbita
convém é bahia redondinha muito embora
haja ainda que não acredita e pretende
provar o contrário
numa notícia cena soul está a ser
planeada uma expedição à antártida como
intuito de encontrar o fim do mundo que
será a forma de uma enorme barreira de
eo saias de assunto dos santos de todos
que não é o uso como teste provou esta
para o fato de que nem todas as opiniões
sobre a natureza são igualmente
respeitáveis
ao contrário do que uma certa moda
parece querer defender e respeitar
valorizado ou melhor a credibilidade da
ciência aaas vem precisamente o fato de
suas teorias tarem cento sujeito a
escrutínio e poderia ser refutados ea
van natta o que acontece com freqüência
como afirmou com muita graça
o físico carlos à zaga é bom ter a mente
aberta mas não tão aberta que o sérvio
por cento a ramarim xadrez parentes
necessário você já pagou inicial seria a
terra é redonda e 1500 quando pesava
escavar o show brasil e pouco tempo
depois o vasco da gama descobrir o
caminho marítimo para a índia
é claro que a serra admite anos aliás
sabemos que a redonda desde há cerca de
4.500 milhões
mas milhão menos milhão após a formação
do sistema solar
isto é esta pergunta não faz qualquer
sentido e vamos substituí la por uma
outra bem mais interessante
será que seria em 1500 de terra era
redonda na realidade sabe que a terra é
redonda desde pelo menos o século quim
antes de cristo
vários sabe os games admirados pitágoras
plantão eles tocam os remédios se
referiram a redondezas da terra
uma das evidências que o sim ficaram foi
disto muitos viajantes surdos quais o
aspecto do chelsea ao trava konder sou
carro para norte o preço era tostes
irena por volta do ano 240 antes chegou
mesmo este mário também da terra através
do método muito simples que todos nós
podemos fazer
comparando inclinação dos raios solares
ao meio-dia em 2 lugar situado
exatamente uma norte do outro eo fel em
si ana aço que o lugar a da figura e
alexandria é norte que é o lugar b
o princípio é muito fácil de entender os
raios do sol só praticamente house
possível uma vez que se encontra muito
distantes nós
a diferença entre as suas inclinações
num e noutro lugar é igual ou água e das
respectivas verticais nas verticais de
colocar são aquelas setinhas que região
do centro da terra que investigado há 11
anos 7,2 graus tosse precisava ainda de
um elemento esta informação que era a
distância entre si ana e alexandria que
estimou em cerca de 5.000 estado através
das informações de vias aéreas
basta fazer agora para calcular o
perímetro da terra resolver uma simples
proporção sem sexo e 14 graus assim os
estados quanto estados haverá em 360
graus
o resultado é 250 mil é exatamente o que
ele está no fim
por que então a questão inicial é
desconhecer se os poços antigos sabiam
ou não da redondeza terra
esta é o mesmo minuto e medieval estando
móvel enciclopédica imagem de um monte
escrita por um clérigo francês em 1945
a imagem mostra dois viajantes que parte
do pólo norte em direções opostas
estes logo ambos para sul para servir em
contar novamente no pólo sul
apare como ilustrador para aceitar
pacificamente o fato dos viajantes não
caírem durante a viagem ainda que acaba
de ficar de cabeça para baixo o que
imagem de mostras a imagem para dúvidas
é que mesmo durante a idade média quando
a ciência da antiguidade parecia sequer
cita se sabia que a terra era volta no
início do século 15 foi traduzida do
grego para o latim é geografia uma
importante obra de otto do geógrafo
greco egípcio cláudio clube eu que viveu
no século 1º da nossa era destruído
diverso mundo habitado desde a europa
ocidental até a china que era acumulada
dos gregos através de uma extensa lista
de coordenadas geográficas dos lugares e
encinas como apresentar até refere que
no plano
esta é uma imagem do século 15
construída há certas coordenadas e das
instruções fornecidas pelo meu dúvidas
houvesse treinamento os intelectuais da
época quanto à face da terra é
respeitadíssimo obras do meu teria
acabado de fazer
no entanto esta apresentação do mundo
tinha muitos problemas que deveriam ser
resolvidos
a seu tempo à parte por exemplo que o se
ali nikou é apresentado como marchado
ainda na primeira metade do século xix
antes de viver feliz por meu ser
difundida na europa os portugueses
iniciaram a exploração sistemática da
costa africana
dobrado do temido cabo gedore 1.434 e
passado recordou se que 35 anos depois
estas missões como iriam post cada vez
mais dos mil dias aos treinos de 9
áfrica em 1487 88
à pergunta sobre se as seguradores e
quem dirigia sabiam da redondeza da
terra parece agora a retórica e incita
mais um e ver ser formada por uma
instituição que parece bem mais isso
santo que as entre os e prometo que será
a última seria é a redondeza da terra
júlio fante 100 mil e 500 renovando para
quem pergunta vocês certamente que forma
da terra conhecidos louvando puxados
vivemos do passado que tenham até
estimado as suas dimensões
era também rolando os astrólogos que há
muitos sabiam que o esperto céu variava
com o título caso só poderia acontecer
se sufista terra fosse curva
no entanto em todos estes casos é
questão era meramente intelectual isto é
a forma eo tamanho do nosso planeta
parecia não ter quaisquer implicações na
vida das pessoas
na estratégia do governante ou em
qualquer atividade prática que não fosse
à procura do conhecimento com as vendas
de viagens oceanos que os europeus é a
partir de meados do século 15
iniciamos uma função na forma como nosso
planeta pessoa ser imaginado ter corrido
e apresentado na pesquisa pequenez do
mundo conhecido os europeus a volta do
baby jane a kuna deu lugar aos grandes
passou-se anos nos quais a curvatura e
também da terra passaram a assumir uma
relevância prática que já nos teria
ignorado a primeira atividade em que
essa relevância se fez sentir foi
provavelmente a navegação oceânica
sobretudo é preciso altura em que foi
ditos metros eo seu nome para a
terminação da posição dos navios no mar
acontece que esse - uma própria turminha
aliás só fazem sentido considerando que
a terra dota
mas o mais antigo episódio histórico é
que forme o tamanho da terra assumir uma
importância estratégica e crítica foi
provavelmente a proposta apresentada por
cristóvão colombo aos respeitosa espanha
fernando isabel em 1486 chegar à índia
isto é as terras situadas a origem e do
continente africano
na verdade não para o oriente mas sim
província
nesta data os forçava os navegadores
portugueses que dobrado os tributos de
nova áfrica o conseguiriam um ano mais
tarde em 1487 mostrando que o oceano
índico não era afinal o marchado como
ter representado pelo meu e quezílias
podiam ser alcançadas através deles que
acontece neste domingo lorient estava
vedado aos leitores espanhóis por duas
bulas papais nas quais estão cia o
domínio eo comércio é exclusivos da
coroa portuguesa ao longo da costa da
áfrica para surdo carro do jogador
a proposta de colombo era muito atrativa
para os respeitosos precisamente porque
é concretizar se permitirá aos níveis
espanhóis tirar partido das felicidades
da terra para chegar às índias sem
beliscar os direitos concedidos pelo
papa a portugal mas só tal só seria
viável se chance de correr não fosse mas
grande em colombo e do abc o momento com
o problema em vez de utilizar os motores
da terra então princípios cujas
dimensões não favoreciam as suas terras
por uma terra substancialmente menor em
que o que mim para a índia vem oscilando
parecia é ainda mais curto do que em mim
para o dia
é importante sublinhar que as metas
américa esperam
então desconhecidas e insuspeitadas
convencer no globo terrestre mais
antigos colegas construído margem da
rainha em 1492 um judeu ou não é tão
radicado em portugal não tendo
conhecimento teve a gente colombo de
arrimo representou o atlético de acordo
com as convicções da época é ainda hoje
a zippo meu isto é com a europa ea
áfrica oriente a direta na figura e xvii
eo japão eu vou acidente há certa é
apenas patético ocian é que o chamamos
oceano atlântico precisamente em 1492
chocou colombo ao mar das caraíbas e as
antigas convencido de ter chegado a
china eo japão
sabemos que se enganou redondamente
não só do tamanho da terra que é
bastante superior ao que eu supunha mas
também no fato de não ter alcançado a
índia
tal não impediu que o fruto desse enorme
engano
a descoberta do novo mundo que ficou
então consigo como as índias ocidentais
que tivesse uma importância histórica
transcendente
uma proposta semelhante à do globo foi
apresentada há cerca de 25 anos mais
tarde o jovem riscar de carlos 1º
espanha por fernando magalhães
nesta altura já os portugueses tinham
chegado ao sudeste asiático e começado a
explorar o comércio das especiarias
muito especial do vale ou escravo que
era produzido nas ilhas lucas tratavas
mais uma vez que uma proposta
irrecusável
há muitos espanhóis procuravam sem êxito
uma passagem do atlântico para o
pacífico com o objetivo de checar as
lucas que os afirmavam estarem situadas
no seu hemisfério de acordo com os
termos do tratado de tordesilhas que
entretanto já havia sido firmado entre
os dois países
a proposta de fernando magalhães
consistia precisamente em provar que era
possível atingir a exigência se
parcerias
gigante para o auxílio e que estas se
situava o lado espanhol
sabemos que para o conseguir sou rude ou
dos melhores especialistas portugueses
em navegação e em cartografia não é
certamente por acaso que no magnífico
mapa possível esperando magnésio é casa
o prémio de espanha desenhado pelos
cartolas português pedro jorge real o
pacífico é pareça mais curto do que é na
realidade e ajuda o pastejo
convenientemente como casas ao leste do
am no meridiano tordesilhas
isto é do lado espanhol mais uma vez a
forma e as dimensões da terra assumir
uma tiro uma enorme importância política
estratégica
sabemos que a missão de magalhães e ao
cabo não foi um fracasso na época em que
se realizou uma vez que não conseguiu
demonstrar que os lucros eram espanholas
e que é possível ir e vir através do
pacífico o que eles não conseguiram no
entanto e aos olhos do mundo de hoje
tratou se da mais importante de viagem
marítima de todos os tempos na qual se
mostrou que a terra era circunda jogável
permitindo o contato entre as índias e
um novo mundo para terminar
ao passarem de um exame para o atlântico
e do atlético para o mundo os povos
europeus nos confrontados com um
dramático aumento de escala de escala
física e com ela das causas do
conhecimento sobre o nosso planeta do
conhecimento geográfico que o primeiro
lugar é do conhecimento dos fenómenos
físicos escala planetária como clima
hoje dos ventos e das correntes e o
magnetismo terrestre e também do
conhecimento do mundo natural que se
encontrava estratificado nas obras dos
sábios clássico da admirado e queria que
chega de forma exponencial quando os
viajantes tomaram contato com novas
terras novos genes e novas espécies
nesta função que te deu aqui e aqui hoje
siga por vocação científica o papel dos
nossos antepassados foi predominante até
25 trios cirque valor da nossa história
em português de todas as condições
sociais e culturais médicos
astrólogos e matemáticos mas também
pilotos cartógrafo e construtor de
instrumentos se viram envolvidos em
tarefas que hoje designado como de
prática e descoberta científica
a propósito da idéia é criar um museu
dos descobrimentos seria para mim é
incompreensível fosso impedir de mostrar
estourar por razões ideológicas difíceis
de entender
os contributos únicos e fascinante do
nosso passado com um muito obrigado
[Aplausos]